there you go how's the calling look
good doing a little hound dog move
for us that's God all right moment
of truth how we feeling here you go
how's it look looks great let's see it
ready dang give us give us a point let's
go welcome to the 2024 discover NHL winner
classic in Seattle Washington it's the 39th
outdoor game in NHL regular season history
as the League's two newest franchises get
together Outdoors we had an opportunity to
play in an unbelievable awesome atmosphere
let's go out and play our asses off that's
how we enjoy this fellas get our two points
and enjoy this opportunity here it's a nice
environment it's a different environment we
still you still got to play the guy across
from that should be your singular Focus let's
go in the first period man our families are
here let's go out there and play like there
is no tomorrow up front ker winning
turbo on the back D Lord and in the
PIP there is no empty seat at T-Mobile Park here
this afternoon they are ready to go for the Winter
Classic I cannot believe hey they're throwing fish
those guys are awesome though in the market they
are awesome it's a treasured memory for every
player that's participated in one of these wow
place is jammed should have brought my phone out
make sure we're talking communicating early on
here let's go 47,000 fans here they can't wait
to drop the pocket welcome to the Winter Classic
here in Seattle let's have a great 2024 and let's
get at it here we go everything's simple and fast
here let's go deep get around it get it going
find it early get him moving early you you'll
have him popped and I'm going to the net step
tun a Time tun a time oh my God I miced up oh
sweet guy here careful how are you doing good
you good happy New Year oh nice look at this
skip is open through the left Circle PS and shoot
safe put it to the net put it to the net who that
b kind of hurt thought he was about to shoot
that out my face scared on our toes keep the
pace up here right side point for Larson now for
Vince G shot from tra boy tol tol in wa be that
good boy tolby C on the board first let's go
gold we're fine we're fine and now Stevenson
has Maro on his right and the pass broken up oh
you got it I knew your arm Barbie head just one
hanger time drive it drive it drive it someone
through Michael yeah wall jack or me here hey
go turn over Mel out in front save by dor save
Jo and he's shaking his head he can't believe
it Seattle Kracken head off with a one- nothing
lead thanks to Ellie to it's tough sleding out
there they're checking well manage the puck well
our second perers have been good when we manage
it well and getting the right side of the line
change and being able to get going while they're
changing all right that's been our advantage so
let's not lose that let's be good at that today
all right let's good here man come on I hated
the advisor say so I put the back one all I'm
like that the whole time huh squinting squinting
yeah like oh it's a nice word on it stay on it job
boys good job is this your first outdoor or you
my first one yeah it's a little bit of fun hey
hard on Puck on you nice nice here's Alexia for
the Kraken nice long shot burn aside by Thompson
and then drive by borgan he scores long rebound
from Logan Thompson and borgan made no mistake
it's two nothing Seattle hey boy wait wait the way
we got to get a lot better here let's go over over
middle again middle good play you got me you got
me Ellie to in left side looks at front Everly on
his back hand right on go turned to side sa Logan
shoot pucks man shoot pucks shoot pucks low low
lowy boy yep yep yep no no no up head
up head up no one likes you on your
team it doesn't matter what he say that
YY can I get my voice Goode barbs up got
to go got to go you got to go man and the
second period comes to an end in Seattle
another good period sets us up where we
want to be here fellas take what's there
shooting mentality all right when we have an
opportunity to make a play especially make a
play inside go ahead and make that play Let's
Get after these guys let's Skate for 20 come on
let's go back in Seattle Hometown Kraken with
a two nothing lead as we get set for the third
period pretty cool atmosphere yeah I'm real eh
it's awesome here we go a little pressure on it
hey we fill off that here let's go let's go come
on we got our Pace come on let's go keep this
pace keep rolling here to keep hunting got to keep
hunting stay physical on their deep stay physical
on them strand rolls it out to the red line Paul
C back to get it stolen away from by Yanni gour
score Yanni gour stole the puck and that goal
was gorgeous boy Gordo stay with a Gord Bo the
atmosphere out there was amazing and this city
is a Hy town now we don't give him anything
easy we don't want to have to play defense
tired keep changing early you got dice right
boys yes yes great job great job wait ESC wait
Gap we're good here let's go let's build let's
go Wing over shooter with Stevie there all
the big guns out there for Vegas Stone Let
It Go through oh Joey dord what an exclamation
Point save on Jack eel it's hell of a save this
crowd cannot believe what they just saw in the
big big screen today was just a special day for
everybody for our team for the city for hockey
today was an incredible day and just so grateful
to be a part of it here comes the final horn joy
aord in the Winter Classic he pitches the shut
out at T-Mobile Park it's a 3 nothing Seattle
Kraken win near the gra go to Center Ice salute
the crowd Tun Up out of boy up herebody and
how about this scene with the players walking
off down to the first base Dugout in front of
a standing ovation oh you just got chills you
know you you felt the energy of the crowd you
know you never know when this is you know might
be my last one right he just very fortunate
very uh very humbled by this opportunity by
the organization has given us that one of the
coolest sporting events that I've been a part
of and the best way to enjoy it and remember
it is exact way you guys did enjoyed it all the
way up the last couple of days and then got the
win today the scene and this event for our city
means a ton but most importantly what you guys
accomplished the two points are most important
for us as we continue on a push here all right
and couldn't be more proud of the effort today
so schultzy you got the Hat man that's one
we're going to remember forever I would give
this to Joey but I don't think he's here yet
so I'm going to go with the first of of the
year uh that was a lot of
fun